the united nations top envoy in
afghanistan is sounding the alarm as
taliban rebels
keep gaining territory ahead of nato's
planned withdrawal
deborah lyons told the u.n security
council everything must be done to get
the taliban and the afghan government
back to the negotiating table on tuesday
the islamist rebels
captured afghanistan's main border
crossing with its northern
neighbor tajikistan here's more of what
lions had to say
more than 50 of afghanistan's 370
districts
have fallen since the beginning of may
most districts have been that have been
taken
surround provincial capitals suggesting
that the taliban are positioning
themselves
to try and take these capitals once
foreign forces
are fully withdrawn the withdrawal
decision was expected
but its speed with the majority of
troops
now already withdrawn was not
all actors have had to adjust to this
new
reality that is unfold
for more we have journalist ali latifi
in kabul joining us
ali this isn't looking good but it is
also not a surprise
there's plenty of critics who will say i
told you so the americans should not be
withdrawing thoughts
i mean i i've heard this argument before
but
there's not really much of an argument
there because the decision has been made
and i think more than saying i told you
so the statement or the question should
be
what's happened in the last 20 years
that has led us to this point
you know what has the united states and
its uh mission here actually
accomplished
20 years later we're still fighting this
battle
and we're still seeing a resurgent
taliban who are able to
influence people and lead them to
believe that you know there's a just
cause for them to like
literally die for you know to the point
where they would be willing to blow
themselves up
um so i think rather than saying i told
you so the better question would be
well what went wrong you know what did
they do wrong what didn't happen that
we're still
facing the situation and it's only
getting worse now
and the comments from the un really
can the international community do
anything
they can do a lot and they have they
should have been doing a lot up
until now you know we know the
government has that so many times they
keep calling it an impulse war
they keep saying that there are
sanctuaries and that there are havens
and support in pakistan
they say that their support in iran you
know these are countries that can put
uh influence and pressure on these
neighboring countries that are
influencing directly
in the war in afghanistan and that are
supplying and arming and
training you know these militant forces
so
there's a lot that they could have been
doing and there's a lot that they can
still be doing and then
in terms of the negotiations there's no
reason that these countries cannot put
pressure on the taliban
to say and the government to say you
have to take these negotiations
seriously
you know we put you up in doha you've
been there since 2011. the government
has been there for the last year
one of you has to start making some real
moves now so
you know it's a lot for them to keep
making statements and condemning things
but they actually have to take action
things that they haven't done over the
last 20 years
i think a lot of people are wondering
how seriously we should consider the
possibility of a complete collapse of
the afghan government and the
establishment of a taliban islamist
state
i personally don't see it happening
because i feel like if you look at what
the taliban has been doing over the last
year and a half two years
they've been going on these diplomatic
missions around the world they've been
going to the neighboring countries
they've been meeting with european
uh american officials all the time and
you know they put out statements saying
you can take your troops but keep your
money here i really don't think that
they want to be a pariah state again
like they were in 1996.
i think they still want some level of
support and legitimacy
so for them to come and overrun call
ball and to start killing people on mats
and like
you know bringing back these draconian
rules
i don't think that's gonna fly again and
hopefully they're realistic enough to
know
that you know the only way through is
some kind of a settlement i mean right
now they're probably trying to put
pressure on everybody
through the war but hopefully they
accept the reality that the only way
forward is the settlement
ali latifi thank you so much for joining
us
thank you afghanistan has
a long history of local militias
switching sides and allegiances
depending on the tide of politics
the sangria militiamen and helmand
province are currently fighting the
taliban
the force counts former insurgents among
their ranks
some say they've been trained by
afghanistan's spy agency as well as
foreign forces what's certain is that
for now
their resistance is stopping though
perhaps only delaying the capture of a
strategic city
gunfire at the gates of leicester the
capital of helmand province
as these defenders of the city fire on
taliban positions
this is the front line and the fighting
is going on every day
the situation isn't good
right now we're here firing all around
us
just days ago i was injured in the
battle
we're fighting the taliban here at
extremely close quarters
these are the sangorians a fierce
fighting force and
hated by the insurgents the militia were
established in 2015
taking its name from a turkey soap opera
about
undercover agents
many here were recruited from the
taliban their mission
to infiltrate and disrupt the insurgency
but for some sangorians the fight is
personal
the taliban are retaking more and more
of afghanistan ahead of the u.s
withdrawal
the sangorians face an enemy that's
better equipped
and growing bolder by the day
there is no need
the taliban use modern weapons like
sniper rifles with night vision
and they come in very close to target
i was injured but i survived
is holding the line
entrances to the city
local officials acknowledge the vital
role of the sangorians in keeping the
taliban at bay
city
sangorians are having a big impact on
the security of helmand province
we're asking the government the ministry
of defence and the national security
director
to recruit more fighters for the
sangorians
to defend helmand province
but that help may never arrive with
government forces on the back foot
and soon to lose american support the
sangorians know they're fighting with
nothing to lose
italy is warning that troop withdrawal
could prompt many afghans to flee
to europe the german port town of
hamburg is already home to a vibrant uh
community of afghan
migrants they're worried about what the
pull-out will mean for
their home country and for relatives
back home
mariam nature and yama wazir live here
in the bilstead neighborhood of hamburg
this district houses one of europe's
largest communities of exiled afghans
nearly forty thousand of whom live here
you can get lamb
fruit and vegetables and afghan baked
goods
and her family fled from afghanistan
when she was just a child
they're really yummy too these cookies
are soft and delicious
she enjoys the traditions of her
homeland but also tells us that exiled
afghans fear the return of the radical
islamist taliban
we get news especially when we call our
families we ask
are you all healthy is everyone still
alive
that's the biggest worry we have so far
fortunately
none of us has been affected but of
course that's a matter of luck
something can always happen
the afghan women's association knows
these worries only too well
for almost 30 years the mostly volunteer
group has been working on projects in
afghanistan
they concentrate on schools clinics and
water supply
chairwoman nadia nashiya is critical of
the rapid withdrawal of international
troops she says they have not fulfilled
their mission in afghanistan
in afghanistan in afghanistan people are
also disappointed with nato and its
allies
because their goals have not been
achieved rule of law
women's liberation and bringing security
to the country
his people in afghanistan begging the
world not to abandon their country now
even if the german troops withdraw
please don't leave us alone the
international community cannot leave
afghanistan alone under
any circumstances and especially germany
should help by being a diplomatic
mediator
because our countries are linked by such
a long friendship
afghans have lived in hamburg for 80
years now the port city has always
attracted traders
even from as far away as afghanistan and
taliban terrorism keeps driving people
out of the country yamaha looks after
refugees and helps them after they
arrive
the women here do not see good prospects
for their homeland
there's always war in afghanistan they
need help
administration is under taliban control
people don't want to admit that the
allied troops are leaving afghanistan
those in surrounding areas are terrified
that their nightmare may become reality
that nightmare would be the rule of the
taliban and the end of democracy
miriam nature and yama wazir fear this
might happen
as do many afghans in hamburg
well let's bring in dr ellen ozino who's
country director for afghanistan at the
german think tank the conrad adenauer
foundation
welcome to dw um i suppose we should
start with the basics really uh
the international mission in afghanistan
has it achieved its goals
well the the um international mission
has has not achieved
all of uh all of its goals and
particularly
it has failed in the main goals of
providing
security for the afghan people and also
in
corruption fighting and providing basic
services
such as electricity or water or
infrastructure
so we have largely failed in these
points i think the only thing where we
have
maybe met our expectations was in
fighting international terrorism so
afghanistan no longer poses a threat or
um jihadi groups no longer pose an
international threat to europe or to the
uh united uh states so
the the country's insecure and corrupt
and has no infrastructure
presumably the troops are leaving this
is purely because um
donald trump decided to withdraw u.s
troops
so everybody else followed suit
well i would not blame it only on on
president trump's decision
but of course we were quite surprised
how fast the troops
then were leaving and how quick and
unconditioned the u.s troops
um decided to withdraw so this came
quite as a surprise but i think
generally i would say that
all international forces in the country
founded time to leave
maybe a bit later but it was not a
question of
whether to leave but rather how and when
to leave that was the main question
so is there a plan either from
international partners or within
afghanistan is there a plan for how to
defeat corruption how to build security
and how to build an infrastructure
once the international presence has gone
well this is very difficult to say
because we have been
claiming or praising afghan ownership
and afghan-led and afghan-owned
construction and peace process since 20
years
and but on the other hand we were kind
of telling them how to do it
and i think now we have come to the
point where where we really say or very
really see what it means afghan
ownership
and i think now it's time to
also have the confidence in the afghans
to build up their country but of course
they need our solidarity
but now of course without their military
strength and the military international
forces in the country
okay thank you for joining us dr dr
elena zino from the conrad adenauer
foundation
thank you
you